[Musica]
no
intanto sono merlino sei un dehor
miglior mirino nuovamente il telefono
meglio che rispondo subito vi ricordate
cosa è successo l'ultima volta pronto
che intruso di cosa stai parlando che
intruso
[Risate]
[Musica]
sembrava un ululato sembrava che
provenisse dal giardino ma almeno
usciamo a controllare in giardino
vabbè allora vado io da solo ok ci
vediamo dopo potete venire anche voi
andiamo dai
per le impronte sono enormi ma chi le
avrà la chat e vanno verso giardino
proviamo a seguirle quale impronte si
interrompono
proviamo a cercare qua in giardino
marino è visto qualcosa
sentito
beh io mi metto qua nella moka e aspetto
di vedere qualcosa
secondo voi che cosa farò meglio
avvisare vitale sicuramente non mi
crederà però almeno questa volta ho una
prova le impronte aspettiamo un poi
vediamo se riusciamo a sentire qualcosa
è che sentito forse è meglio fissare
vitale e vitale vitale che è successo a
berlino stavo urlando no nuovo berlino è
che la linea di arrivo
ascolta o no non si sente più vieni con
me devo farti vedere una cosa ci sono
delle impronte qui vieni oltre ecco
proprio qua guarda che cosa può essere
ma sono da impronte di merlino
ma come fa ad essere le impronte di
berlino quella quanto sono grati pronta
a mettere assieme la zampa di berlino
molto più piccola di questa sì
effettivamente non è stampa enorme cosa
può essere ho capito l'hai fatto apposta
per farmi uno scherzo lo era già tutto
no non voglio farti nessuno scherzo
perché dovrei farti uno scherzo semmai
sei tu che potresti farmi uno scherzo
io ti ho fatto uno scherzo la prima
volta che l'ho averlo ai fatti tu queste
impronte no non ho fatto io davvero ho
sentito un ululato prima c'è qualcosa
qua in giardino e poi queste impronte
vanno verso il giardino quindi se un
animale o una creatura in giardino ma no
sono solo delle macchie per terra
ma non ti preoccupare quale animale
potrebbe nascondersi in giardino con
queste impronte
vabbè io vado dai non ci pensare tanto
sono solo delle macchie si vede
benissimo guarda
mica sono delle impronte queste sì che
sono delle in prova o come sospettavo
anche questa volta vitale non ci crede
pure a me sembrano proprio delle zampe
pro vorrei mettermi nella maga e aspetto
che si senta qualcosa si sta proprio
bene
[Musica]
beh io mi sa che fa sul repo sino
avvisatemi se vedete ho sentito qualcosa
[Musica]
ho sentito un rumore strano
se qualcuno forse mi sono addormentata
vabbè
[Applauso]
[Musica]
come si fa in camera ma niente stavo sul
cellulare un po marino dirglielo anche
tu che cosa abbiamo visto guarda pure la
sua riguarda questa spiega ti stai
guardando a response guarda questa lazio
vicino alla macro non vedo niente vedo
solo le tue scarpe lì sì perché lasciato
le scarpe di esse è venuto a cui scalza
nero sull'amaca stavo dormendo mi sono
addormentata e ho visto una zampa po
degli artigli deve essere lo stesso che
ha lasciato le impronte fuori dalla
porta e un e volendo vedere qualcosa
bolliger di una creatura sei scappato da
una zampa con gli attivi fin dalla makam
ba sarà stato merlino che voleva salire
sulla stampa enorme con degli artigli
enorme anzi cui erano due zampe anche
non mi hanno visto che avete visto è
vero c'è qualcosa fuori devi andare a
controllare aspetta un momento però hai
detto che ti sei addormentato nella
marca quindi magari stavi sognando
oppure magari stavi sognando però è
arrivato merlino io volevo salutarti di
berlino esame di berlino solo così la
data che ho visto io era così grande e
così grande
devo subito uscire oppure controllare il
giardino prima che entri dentro casa che
animale potrebbe essere con una zampa
così grande è lo stesso che ha lasciato
le impronte fuori
andiamo a controllare se ci sono altre
impronte è il primato a controllare ok
vai verso l'amica io controllo qua
intorno c'è qualcosa che c'è è visto
qualcosa
che c'è
dove sono le mie scarpe li hai presi e
tu no ma vada mie scarpe qui sembra un
forum picchiato
qualcuno ha rosicchiato la mia scarpa
sarà stato martino no è stata la
creatura la creatura dove l'acqua lo
vedo non può essere stato berlino era
sempre con noi deve essere all'altra
scarpa ok tu controlla qua in giardino
cerca la scarpa qua io la cerco dentro
casa ok va bene alla ricerca della
scarpa perduta come sempre vitale non mi
crede morta e voi avete visto qualcosa e
mi credete lasciata mi piace qui sotto
ok anche se non penso proprio che sia in
casa se fosse in casa significherebbe
che quella creatura con le zampe bianche
è entrata dentro casa e non è possibile
che sia entrata dentro casa visto che ho
sempre chiuso la porta
se qualcosa sopra alla scala non mi dire
che la fede tempi e voi la mia scarpa
che cosa si fa ma sopra al scale che
portano la soffitta
questo vuol dire solo una cosa che la
creatura è entrata in casa ed è salita
su in soffitta e qualcuno dovrà andare a
controllare ovviamente quel qualcuno
sarò io perché vitale continua non
credermi eccoti purtroppo non ha trovato
niente solo la scarpa che abbiamo visto
vicino alla porta
l'ho trovata io ai trovata tu sopra alle
scale sai che cosa vuol dire questo che
c'è uno scapolo scala no vuol dire che
dirvi la creatura ha preso un altra
scarpa ed è salita in soffitta e merlino
in giardino cosa subito controllare
berlino vitale continua a pensare che
sia merlino ma in un lato proviene dalla
soffitta
vi ricordate l'ultima volta che ho
risposto al telefono si vedeva un occhio
rosso può essere l'occhio della creatura
la devo andare a controllare
altrimenti vitale non mi crederà andiamo
[Musica]